cuando tomas una clase de química
general normalmente tienes que memorizar
los nombres de algunos de los compuestos
poli atómicos más comunes vayamos a
través de una lista de algunos que
podrías ver en tu clase empezaremos con
un cateo nac y unión positivamente
cargado nh4 más el llamado el guión de
amonio y si nos referimos a uniones hay
muchos años que deberías conocer se h 13
- es el ión de acetato
n menos es el ión de cianuro o h - es el
ión de hidróxido mn
4 - es el ión de permanganato y cuando
comparas al n
3 - contra el no2 - mira las
terminaciones entonces n o 3 - es un
nitrato entonces tenemos el sufijo ato
que significa más oxígeno en contraste
con el sufijo hito que significa menor
cantidad de oxígeno entonces podemos ver
que el nitrato tiene 3 oxígenos y el
nitrito tiene 2 oxígenos y esa
terminación es importante porque va a
ayudarte con algunos de los otros iones
poli atómicos
por ejemplo veamos el siguiente conjunto
de 4 iones entonces veamos ser clorato
el clorato tiene 3 oxígenos
3 - 1 y el cloro tiene menos oxígenos
tiene 2 oxígenos aquí cl o 2 - entonces
tenemos a pto que significa más e ito
que significa menos oxígenos y que pasa
con el perclorato aquí tenemos clorato
pero se añadió el prefijo per y el
prefijo per significa un oxígeno más
entonces perclorato significa un oxígeno
más que el clorato el clorato tenía 3
oxígenos cierto y para el perclorato
agregamos uno más y entonces tenemos 4
así que el perclorato es cl o 4 - a
continuación veamos el hipoclorito ya
hablamos del cloro aquí y aquí tenemos
el cloro entonces ponemos un prefijo
tipo en frente de él y pos significa 1 -
si vemos el cloro tenemos 2 oxígenos
1 ahora sólo tenemos un oxígeno entonces
este tiene que ser el guión de
hipoclorito
pudimos haber hecho esto para distintos
halógenos aquí estamos tratando con el
cloro entonces en lugar de cl o 3 -
digamos que tenemos
br o 3 menos
el otro es menos explorado pero aquí
tenemos bromo en lugar de cloro así que
esto será bromato entonces hay otro jon
paul y atómico y podemos hacer otro
ejemplo en lugar de cl o menos que es
hipoclorito podríamos tener b r
- que entonces sería y prometo este
sería
pero
y tú
bien ahora veamos el siguiente conjunto
de iones poli atómicos entonces hagamos
algo de espacio aquí abajo tenemos ese o
42 menos que llamado sulfato tenemos la
terminación ato y tenemos 4 oxígenos si
tenemos 3 oxígenos so3 2 - esto es
sulfito porque esto significa menos
oxígenos y qué pasa si tomamos sulfato
que es ese o 42 - y agregáramos h más
entonces h más
con ese o 42 - debería darnos hs o 4 y
en lugar de un 2 negativo
12 - tenemos solo menos uno porque
agregamos una carga positiva entonces
una carga positiva con dos cargas
negativas nos da una carga negativa hs o
4 - el llamado añón hidrógeno sulfato o
también puedes haber escuchado sulfato
para este
el siguiente es 03 2 - es llamado
carbonato entonces si agregamos un h más
al ceo 32 - obtenemos h 03 y vamos de
menos 2 a menos 1 porque estamos
agregando una carga positiva que
entonces
hc o 3 - el llamado hidrógeno carbonato
o también puedes haber escuchado mucho
que le llaman bicarbonato a continuación
tenemos pe o 43 menos que llamado
fosfato y si agregamos un h más al
fosfato piensa en lo que vamos a obtener
vamos a obtener hp o 4 y en lugar de 3 -
como estamos agregando una carga
positiva vamos a obtener 2 - y llamamos
a este hidrógeno fosfato muy bien ahora
agreguemos un protón al hidrógeno
fosfato agregamos un h más al hidrógeno
fosfato y eso nos da h 2b o 4 y vamos de
2 menos a 1 - entonces h 2 p 4 - el
llamado de hidrógeno fosfato
bien continuamos con un último conjunto
de iones poli atómicos por conocer
entonces tenemos 0 42 menos que llamado
cromato y si tenemos dos cromos es decir
cr 2 o 72 - estoy llamado de cromatos el
siguiente ese 2 o 42 menos que llamado
jon de oxalato y tenemos otros dos menos
que llamado peróxido y aquí tenemos ese
cn - que llamamos yo sea nato
entonces para ti o piensa en el sulfuro
si has visto el prefijo tío ahí para el
siguiente tenemos sulfuro presente de
nuevo es ese 2 o 3 2 - y este llamado
dio sulfato entonces podrías ver algunos
iones poli atómicos extra en tu clase
pero estos son los que se estudian más
frecuentemente así que asegúrate de
memorizar estos iones poli atómicos